montréal veut proscrire le gaspillage
nous interdirons donc au grand
générateur aux établissements
d'enseignement et aux hôpitaux de jeter
les aliments dont la fraîcheur ne les
satisfait pas et nous allons plutôt les
encourager à trouver des partenariats
avec des banques alimentaires
l'industrie alimentaire a déjà pris les
devants à travers le québec la majorité
des banques alimentaires sont tous en
association avec les grandes chaînes de
détaillants et leurs réseaux de
marcheurs 50% des magasins des grandes
enseignes provigo métro et iga transige
avec les banques alimentaires de façon
volontaire nous sommes rendus à un peu
plus de 400 magasins qui nous permet de
ramasser mais cela ne suffit pas à
l'administration municipale qui prévoit
des mesures coercitives des amendes pour
convaincre les récalcitrants de faire
très attention aux crédits des
problématiques opérationnelles
financières et autres et logistique qui
vont peut-être freiné des initiatives
kit fonctionne déjà très bien dans le
marché moisson montréal en est à sa
sixième année de collaboration avec les
grandes enseignes ont récupéré l'année
passée d'exemple plus d'un million de
kilogrammes de nourriture dans plus
symphoniques la gamme de biens
l'organisme projette de se doter d'une
cuisine pour blanchir et surgelés les
légumes afin d'en prolonger la durée de
vie mais il devra le financer à l'instar
des autres banques alimentaires qui
manque d espace pour recueillir
davantage de damery nous manque des
infrastructures pour être capable de
mieux récupérer
on parle aussi de plus d'équipements
pour être capable de bien gérer ces
denrées qui nous proviennent bana on ne
peut pas saturé on veut pas non plus
mettre tout le fardeau sur les banques
alimentaires donc on a aussi d'autres
d'autres avenues les banques
alimentaires du québec ont lancé une
vaste campagne de financement à laquelle
les grandes épiceries contribuer
l'objectif est de recueillir 15 millions
de dollars d'ici 2023 ici maxime
bertrand radio canada mon rêve